this video is sponsored by Squarespace
to say the world of anime is full of
strong girls is an understatement for
every edgy hero there's the trusty
heroine ready to fight by his side the
side character who's a powerful figure
of admiration or the female villain that
serves as the ultimate obstacle
eventually our journey through the
various offerings of the anime world
would inevitably let our paths cross
with these powerful women so for this
list here are some of the badass or
plain overpowered women in anime that
could give anyone a run for their money
[Music]
we start off with mikasa ackerman from
attack on titan Mikasa is a no brainer
inclusion to this list I mean anyone
who's watched attack on Titan would rag
the tough no-nonsense Mikasa as one of
the top fighters in the series the many
seasons of attack on Titan are filled
with her exploits as a member of the
survey corpse how many times have you
seen people dread and respect her due to
her prowess in battle I mean in some
ways she does better in batter than
eren's Titan form a couple of times
early on in the story - watch out Titans
there's little you can do to escape your
fate when this lady starts to cut you
down with grace and speed
[Music]
hoser scarlet makes her way to the
number nine spot on the list since their
introduction few women in fairy tale
match the impact in aura
Arthur boasts miles ahead of the main
cast she impresses in her appearances
thanks to her various different armor
always having something appropriate for
any opponent as if taking down foes that
threaten the guild and her friends isn't
enough though she's infallible in the
face of adversity easily taking on
challenges such as facing hundreds of
powerful monsters in one go however
versatility isn't eras greatest strength
as with fairy tale members it's her
uncanny will to keep fighting for her
friends that makes her truly powerful
[Music]
luring to the eight spot on our list is
Mary Oh Leona Vermillion Mary Oh Leona
bursts onto the scene with a claim that
she's never been defeated in battle now
while this may be an absurd or generic
claim according to anime standards she
more than proves her worth with their
amazing fire powers her mighty flames
allow her to brutalize enemies with ease
and overcome spells of all sorts now it
wouldn't be a stretch to say that she's
one of the most powerful Knights in the
kingdom in terms of physical combat
fitting for the leader of the Crimson
lions in fact the only reason she
doesn't start off as the captain of the
Lions is that she just doesn't feel like
getting the position in terms of
strength
she'd more than qualify for the role in
her noteworthy battle against Riya she
easily burns through all the spells
thrown at her through sheer power now
that's power fitting for one who has the
potential to become wizard king
[Music]
sitting in the seventh spot we have all
tire from recreate errs re-creators main
villain easily stands tall above all the
other badasses in the show while the
other creations have their own slew of
powers and moments not one can match
what all Tire has installed all tires
blessed with loads of powers fitting for
any primary antagonist besides their
combat skills and ability to fly alter
has a set of reality warper abilities -
what's more further powers are added to
her arsenal as the story goes on thanks
to her being able to adapt and weaponize
bang content of her in the end the
heroes don't even manage to defeat you
in battle if that isn't an outright
bragging rights award then I don't know
what is
merci Teresa from Claymore take six
place on the list long regarded as an
unparalleled fighter within the ranks of
claymores Teresa of the faint smile
easily finds her way to the list I mean
just take a look at her official stats
and you can see how powerful she really
is
make no mistake Teresa is an equal in
combat ability yoky perception and yoky
reserve even without fighting a full
strength
she takes little effort in overpowering
multiple claymores of her generation
further showing the huge gap between her
number one and the next ones in line in
the end the only way to defeat her is
through offhanded tactics and sneak
attacks should you never let her guard
down Teresa is literally my impossible
to beat truly a terrifying Claymore to
face in battle
at this place we find as death leader of
the jaegers in a commie got killed
a true sadist as death fits perfectly in
this list of badass anime women living
under her father's philosophy of
survival of the fittest general as death
takes pleasure in violence and brutality
throughout a car maker kill she's
probably the deadliest foe that night
raid contends with if not for some
varying situations I've no doubt that
she's capable of wiping the floor with
night ray there's several times over and
over we still have to consider her
unparalleled ice powers to those that
culminate and have being able to freeze
time itself
[Applause]
tatsumaki blows past the competition to
make it to fourth place don't
underestimate this petite little
spitfire the second highest ranked hero
in the hero association brash moody
confident and sometimes temperamental
such traits are to be expected from
someone as strong as her after all Tatsu
marques claim to fame is being the most
powerful espera in the series in a world
such as one punch man's being the best
that anything is no easy task
her psychic powers are second to none
and she showcases them with feats such
as repelling attacks from Boris's
spaceship in fact her greatest enemy is
actually herself the only thing stopping
her from running wild is that her powers
can be unpredictable and can destabilize
Oh
[Music]
or it's kind of bad
[Music]
three two as we approach the top three
badass or overpowered women at anime
let's turn our attention to one pieces
big mom now for another villain on the
list
Charlotte Lin Lin better known as big
mom is the only female member among the
four Emperor's in one piece don't her
appearance for you though
despite being old and looking out of
shape she's more than capable of chasing
after opponents and kicking ass in
battle her devil fruit which allows her
to absorb powers and grant inanimate
objects sentience is also one very
powerful and unique ability it's not as
if she has to train a lot to get to this
point - she was born to be abnormally
strong and her bad ass showing started
all the way when she was just five years
old at the age of six she already had a
bounty but she was simply growing
stronger and stronger with age
Shiki claims her places second-best on a
list of badass women her grey morality
overpowered abilities bloodlust and
other hidden depths make her one of the
coolest and more badass characters in
type-moon watching her growth as a
person and her developing relationship
with mickey er make the garden of
sinners a very fun watch even INRI
watches Nishiki has incredible endurance
agility and strength she was capable of
dispatching a horde of undead or even
spirit Light Beings especially when in
possession of a katana however what
sensor above and beyond most if not
every single being in her universe is
her mystic eyes of death perception an
ability that allows the user to perceive
the death of something living or
nonliving in the form of lines and dots
on the target when cut or stabbed it
causes the object to be sliced and
killed with ease or in the case of the
dots a rays of being or objects entire
existence completely
[Music]
finally number one on our list is Kaguya
who else better to top our list other
than the first chakra user in the naruto
universe we already knew about Madara
and how broken he was both in the past
and in his reincarnated forming the
great ninja war how about someone to up
the ante just as things already looked
bleak enough for our heroes introducing
Kaguya otsutsuki she makes her return as
an even greater threat than Madara
boasting such insane abilities such as
absorbing everyone's chakra and some
reality warper abilities too I mean
she's so powerful that even Naruto and
Sasuke conclude that the only way to
truly defeat her in her revived form is
to once again steal her indeed it takes
the combined efforts of Team seven to
finally seal her and end her threat to
the ninja world once and for all
before in this video I'd like to give a
shout out to this video sponsor
Squarespace Squarespace is one of the
easiest to use and beautiful website
development tools out there with 24/7
365 days support some of the world's
biggest companies Hollywood stars and
even your favorite youtubers use
Squarespace to create amazing sites that
is super simple to maintain it's
flexible for any kind of website for
musicians designers artists or if you
just want to open an anime blogging
website you can do it all right here you
don't even need to have any website
coding experience either Squarespace has
tons of modern templates to choose from
that have already been crafted by their
world-class design team I'm actually
creating my own website using
Squarespace to where I'll be posting
some exclusive content be sure to stay
tuned to future episodes where I'll be
showing off my progress Squarespace is
offering my viewers 10% off your first
purchase with them just go to
Squarespace comm / Vinnie tube that's VI
n III tu b e or just click the link in
the description to sign up and start
building your online presence that I'll
do for now make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more anime content and
I'll see you next time on vide tube
you